hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome to undertale now this is
rapidly becoming one of the most popular
games in recent years and the reason for
that is at least according to my friends
in real life and my friends on YouTube
that tell me that I have to play this
game and you guys out there who tell me
that I have to play it and I have to
play it a very specific way is because
of the effect your choices have on the
world around and that the effect is so
profound that if you were to beat the
game one time and then start up the game
again and played a different way the
choices that you made in the first
playthrough would still have an effect
on the second playthrough now the reason
I'm telling you guys this is because you
guys have told me that I should play it
in a pacifist way and I would agree
because normally when I play these types
of games that have choices I would take
it in a pacifist attitude that being
said this is me we're talking about here
I don't choice good and I also don't
know what the choices are going to be
when I come to this I know a lot about
the game but I don't know a lot about
the story of the game but one of the
things that I'm also very very very
excited for is that supposedly this game
is either indirectly or directly
inspired by mother3 which is the
Japanese only sequel to earthbound which
is one of my favorite games of all time
I love that game to death it is so weird
so bizarre and I'm going to name my
fallen human Tim cuz he or she was tiny
and itty-bitty and adorable and probably
entered a world of monsters there was an
intro movie oh there was an intro movie
to all this where it was showing that
the world used to be comprised of
monsters and humans and this little
child whose is oh oh I thought your eyes
were closed okay never mind then this
child fell down into a hole after
climbing a mountain that legend says no
one returns from after climbing up and
we're starting to see yl oh hi how's it
going there howdy i'm flowey flowey the
flower hmm you're new to the underground
yeah golly you must be so confused
someone ought to teach you how things
work around here I guess little old me
will have to do sorry my voice kinda
gave out there ready
here we go I don't know if I'm ready I
don't exactly know what this is gonna
press okay see that hot that is your
soul the very combination of your being
oh your soul starts off weak but you can
grow strong if you gain a lot of little
what's nice stand for why love of course
you want some love don't you
I don't know I'm a child don't worry
I'll share some with you wink okay down
here love is shared through little
little white friendliness pellets oh
okay
are you ready move around get as much as
you can oh oh oh oh oh oh in this world
it's kill or be killed holy crap why
would anyone pass up an opportunity like
this oh no no no no no no okay
oh no why did you do this to me oh hey
what hello oh by flowey hello
was a terrible creature torturing such a
poor innocent youth I do not be afraid
my child
I am toriel caretaker of the ruins I
passed through this place every day see
if anyone has fallen down you are the
first human to come here in a long time
come I will guide you through the
catacombs okay this way unless I'm
giving you a very deep voice and you're
actually a lady which I apologize the
best that I can do so we're just gonna
pretend like this accurate that actually
spooked me when the flower turned evil I
would say my heart actually stuff or is
it gonna had no idea what was going on
is there anything else to explore I
don't know if this game involves a lot
of exploration or if it's very linear
path which involves many branching paths
because of story that's a good question
should I still be following you is the
question the shadow of the ruins looms
above filling you with determination HP
fully restored oh oh oh okay
goody goody gumdrops I'm glad that this
is the way that it is alrighty then
welcome to your new home innocent one I
can't do any higher of a voice I have a
naturally deep voice it's not gonna work
allow me to educate you in the operation
of the ruins
the rules are full of puzzles ancient
fusions between divert excuse me of
diversions and door keys one must solve
them to move from please adjust yourself
to the sight of them okay so was I
supposed to follow the pattern that you
did only the fearless may proceed brave
ones foolish ones both walk not the
middle road alrighty then what happens
if I press the other buttons did I do
something bad
hello to make progress here you will
need to trigger several switches not
worry I have labeled the ones that you
need to flip
well there's awfully nice of you plus
press Z to read signs okay I would have
known that because I already did that
stay on the path okay is that you
considered marking please press this
switch toriel okay what happens if I
don't listen what happens if I press the
other switch go on press the switch on
the left what happens if I press the
switch on the right wait no no no no no
no you want to press the other which I
even labeled it for you
really but Bank okay
splendid I am proud of you little one
let us move to the next room I literally
am Tiny Tim that's adorable but what
happens if I press the other one this
which doesn't even work
oh it was a fakie ah so the illusion of
choice as a human living in the
underground monsters may attack you you
weren't scottish you'll need this to be
prepared for the situation however
boring not
the process is simple when you encounter
a monster you will enter a fight while
you are in a fight strike up a friendly
conversation stall for time
I will come to resolve the conflict
practice talking to the dummy
oh ok I'm with it I get it
oh you encountered the dummy I'm gonna
talk to this dummy it's gonna be fun
time why can I not how do i I'm trying
to move two different options boink
I didn't no no no no no no no I didn't
know I didn't oh oh I didn't mean to
therefore talking we do not wanna hurt
anybody do we come now but I didn't I I
tried I tried to mouse over to the other
ones it wouldn't let me
I really tried I pushed the buttons and
everything it wasn't my fault I hope
that doesn't have a profound effect
there is another puzzle in this room I
wondered if you can solve it I wondered
if I can get your voice consistent
throughout this series Oh Oh froggit
your visit do you have eyes on your
nipples is that what I'm seeing right
here okay now I can move over so I just
wouldn't let me before axe how about I
complimented you have lovely eyeball
nipples there didn't understand what you
said but was flattered anyway okay good
good good good
hello okay well bye then you won you are
nothing and nothing good good good good
good good good
the western room is in the eastern rooms
great I don't know what that means
damn hello this is the puzzle but here
take my hand for a moment am I supposed
to memorize this pattern because I don't
know if I'm gonna remember it all seems
a little complicated ok I'm gonna try my
best
puzzles seem a little too dangerous for
now but I could go back I can okay down
here okay I think I remember it it was
yeah here down here okay so I could go
back but I don't know if there was any
benefit to be actually going back there
might not have been I might just be
backtracking for no damn reason cuz
there could be something else here that
I need but then again I don't know if
this game is actually something that's
gonna hide things from me or if it's
gonna be something that I kinda just
need to follow forward because that
could entirely be what I need to do but
at the same time I don't know if it's
what I need to do because I'm I'm a
little Lawson confused I'm just little
Tim Tim in a world and pain and
suffering you've done excellently thus
far my child however I have a difficult
request to ask of you I would like you
to walk to the end of the room by
yourself
Wow forgive me for this oh no no please
I hate being all by myself hunters will
Tim Tim Gatling symptom can get a little
help you're not gonna leave little Tim
Tim all by himself aware I'm so scared
I'm so lonely I don't know what I'm
doing I want my mommy lose em Tim needs
a head wait a minute something doesn't
seem right here little Tim Tims using
this little brain brain to come up with
a solution to this puzzle I oh oh I
thought it was gonna be okay huh oh hey
how's it going greetings my child do not
worry I didn't
you I was merely behind this pillar the
whole time
well the pillar was all the way at the
end of the room thank you for trusting
me however there was an important reason
for this exercise ah to test your
independence I must attend to some
business and you must stay alone for a
while please remain here
it's too dangerous to explore by
yourself I have an idea I will give you
a cellphone I don't know if you know
what this magical device is in the off
year of 2020 1x if you nee have a need
for anything just kool be good all right
okay I'm glad I don't have to do your
voice anymore because it was straining
me not not like on my voice box just
mentally I was not able to process
pretty much anything you were doing okay
here we go little jammed him going off
oh is that frog it ring hello
this is toriel you have not left the
room have you there are a few puzzles
ahead that I have yet to explain it
would be dangerous to try and solve them
yourself be good all right click okay
hello ribbit ribbit excuse me human I
have some advice for you about battling
monsters if you act a certain way or
fight until you almost defeat them then
might not want to battle you anymore if
a monster does not want to fight you
please use some mercy human ribbit that
was a lot contained in a single ribbit
but I'm just a little Tim Tim I don't
probably know any better playfully
crinkling through the leaves fill you
fills you with determination does it now
well I didn't know about that goal leaf
pile saved oh oh hello wimps
inapproachable
hello hi wimzie console are you ok
halfway through your first word wimps in
person to tears and runs away oh ok
I'm sorry I was just trying to make you
feel better little Tim Tims lost in this
little world why would I want to do
nothing
oh-oh-oh am i dead this is what death is
oh ah interesting
oh hello hi there
oh hey Wilson how you doing again are
you okay
can I get you anything like a cup of
coffee
oh all right then bye Winston hope you
have a lovely day I'll just be somewhere
over here apparently pudding hello this
is toriel for no reason in particular
which do you prefer cinnamon or
butterscotch oh I like butterscotch
although I do like cinnamon rolls but if
we're talking about just straight-up
cinnamon or butterscotch I do like
butterscotch oh I see
thank you very much is he gonna give me
a little treat he she I don't really
know I hope I'm doing the voice just
okay hello this is toriel yes who else
would it be
you do not dislike cinnamon do you I
know that your preference is but would
you turn up your nose if you found it on
your plate right all right I understand
thank you for being patient by the way
um I don't mind cinnamon but I didn't
actually I didn't get to answer the
question three out of four great I need
us to I three out of four gray box
recommend you push them so should I push
that what is this one of the ones that
doesn't want to be pushed
Oh oh hello Winson are you okay can I
check on you are you okay too sensitive
to fight well that's okay I have known
you all you have a choice you go Moo Oh
am I
Winston continues to mutter abala jeez I
I didn't I didn't mean it's okay Winston
you can you can fight me you can throw a
punch okay bye-bye wimp s'en I love you
have a good day
man that's actually really cool because
like I people didn't even need to
explain to me to do the pacifist route
because I would have done it anyway
oh no oh I see it's an exact duplicate
of what its gonna be
ah please don't step on the leaves I'll
try not to burn my heart Oh
mold small hello moe flirt hey how you
doing you wiggle your hips hold small oh
okay
what a meaning Oh sexy wiggle Oh
oh god is this a poem my god it's a
bullet-hell a ruminating why are you
ruminating imitate you lie a mobile with
mold mall you feel like you understand
the world a little better
slime sounds I don't know what you want
from me little wiggler waits pensively
maybe I should check on you
stereotypical curvaceous curvaceously
attractive Lily are we going when is
that that really are we gonna go with
that probe a mold of jell-o maybe I
could try flirting again hey how you
doing okay apparently not I have no idea
what you want from me I don't know what
I'm supposed to be doing I seem to be
failing miserably oh gosh maybe I could
mercy spare huh take that I guess did I
do it I think I did it I think I did a
thing I did it I was somehow that was
wrong with my pen who knows
okay so I know what I needs me to do
needs me to follow the path that was in
the leaves so it was like oh god ah
didn't you read the sign oh ho sorry I'm
sorry
oh I thought I was gonna fall hello foot
argit's how's it going there buddies you
look mmm you look good
oh plus just deeply well apparently only
flirted with the one of them oh god oh
god
oh hey filled with the smell of mustard
see why I'm like I have a lot of
questions about this world in general
but that one seems to stand out as a
little bit weird maybe I could threaten
you
er didn't understand what you said what
was scared anyway yeah that's right
maybe you don't want to mess with me
ruh-oh whoa hey watch out there so could
I just mercy spare you'll be okay you'll
be all right wait so is this is
literally all of us he's gonna be solved
by me sparing them apparently not
oh because I didn't like ow I didn't oh
I didn't I didn't complement this one
yeah there you go
you know you know what's up so I got a
what I gotta do is I gotta act and then
I can spare them cuz otherwise they
don't want to mess with any of me
reluctant to fight you okay you're good
all right oh that's cool oh that's cool
oh [ __ ]
I was one more over wasn't it a poopy
poopy pants damn it damn it damn it damn
it damn it damn it damn it damn it
little Tim Tims angry little Jim Tim's
not gonna tolerate this anymore
little Tim Tims up in arms about this
bull little Jim Tim ain't too happy bout
none of this okay so it was all the way
over Hazzard oh no my heart
hello froggit how's he doing it you're
lookin good
you're looking lovely today I know right
I know I know I know I don't actually
know I'm just saying I know because I I
don't understand how to talk to you but
it's the best I can do at this point
okay all right you have a good one I'll
be on my way
you bye bye now you bye bye now you bye
bye now okay bye-bye
all right cool bye bye okay I did it
wait three out of four rocks these would
be oh man these are hey hey come on now
I'm trying to do a thing here just okay
okay just okay come on okay there we go
got it okay
we're good I'm getting gold just not
experience okay so
whoa there partner who said you could
push me around hmm so you asking me to
move over there
okay just for you pumpkin thanks Rocky
come on a little farther come on just
for me you want me to move some mwah all
righty
how's this what oh no come on wrong way
that was the wrong direction
Oh think I got it I should have gone in
one direction ah got it yeah thanks
buddy was it helpful you do the ball
come on now don't be like that hmm
you want me to Steve yeah you're giving
me a real workout okay you can move down
I would have been impaled to death oh my
heart
hello I'm old small I'm gonna just you
know wiggle my hips at y'all Winky Winky
to wink sexy with a wiggle Oh God not
this Oh God Oh God oh crap
dang it are you ruminating okay
ruminating enough for me to get away
okay bye I probably shouldn't left for
the El behind knowing the mouse might
one day leave its hole and get the
cheese it fills you with determination
okay so should I not take the cheese
does that put your same
oh it's like the Freddy knows okay this
cheese has been here quite a long time
it's stuck to the table I couldn't take
it if I wanted to so I guess I'll just
be on my with your ghost hello
my remember are they gone yet remember
mama this ghost keeps saying Z how
repeatedly oh okay
I thought he was actually doing the
thing if it was forced oh I don't wanna
I don't wanna I gotta they also do so
maybe I could maybe I could I mean it's
not too terribly violent would it be
yeah sure
here comes napstablook nap-nap stable
look nap napstablook cheer you gave
napstablook a patient smile you're doing
great
I know things are going good for you
you're gonna be shy uh what are those
tears Oh God
Oh oh wow wow wow holy crap napstablook
looks just a little bit better how about
one more you're looking good today
I just weigh you down would you no don't
whoa oh that's cool
oh that's okay maybe I could sit okay
you're fine oh no you're crying
oh the poor ghost who wouldn't play this
and murder them they're so cute it's
okay a little homey joke yeah I know
it's gonna be okay you're gonna do just
fine you're an awesome ghost I believe
in you
oh okay one more
gosh you're high maintenance ghosts here
I'm trying to make you feel better and
this is just getting in my way because I
got places to be
one more wants to show me something Lea
let let you try what
Oh what I call it dapper blue that's
nice that's really nice wow you look
great
how do I tell you you look great I'm
gonna flare with you oh no oh no I
usually come to the wounds because
there's nobody around but today I met
somebody nice Oh
I'm rambling again I'll get out of your
way huh
where'd you get out of my way - you just
vanished into nothingness I love Roget
did you miss it
spider bake sale town and to the right
come eat food made by spiders for
spiders of spiders is the food made of
spiders I don't think I want to eat
spiders seems counterintuitive do your
food bait tail spider bake sale all
proceeds go to real spiders really Oh
okay some spiders crawl down gave you a
doughnut oh I don't have that money okay
let's be on my way then I don't have
enough gold for that but thanks for the
doughnut made of spiders can't wait to
eat it
I'm sure it's gonna be good you're using
f4 can make you have a full screen but
what does f4 stand for for frogs I have
only seen a maximum of three frogs in
this room this is troubling to say the
race ribbit that actually talked to you
ribbit ribbit huh my friend never
listens to me whenever I talk they skip
through my words by pressing X oh that's
right
pressing ax well at least you listen to
me okay bye oh my heart honey Oh Luke's
hello Luke's are you doing don't pick I
don't want to pick on finally someone
gets it I do get it well hey we'll hey
wait you don't get it hey don't touch me
ah okay Luke's is gazing at me can I
oh five gold I need more gold I'm gonna
form up a little gold here because I
wanted to posit it didn't spiderweb
maybe I'll get a big spider donut in the
big web don't mind me I'm just kicking
around till enemies find me okay I think
I have enough gold now so I should be
able to go down here and deposit a tune
and Megan you're us go for it some
spiders crawled down and gave you a jug
is it a jug of spiders is it filled with
spiders spiders for my face when I go to
bed at night or they're gonna crawl up
my nose and all my other orifices
oh boy I'm glad I have that oh boy
ribbit ribbit I've heard you're quite
merciful for a home surely you know why
now a monster was a yellow name when you
couldn't spared it I did not know that I
was not paying attention to anything see
very it's a very helpful it's bad I feel
very it's helpful in bed a helpful
oh it is rather helpful remember sparing
is just saying you won't fight maybe one
day you'll have to do it even if the
name isn't yellow ah
oh hey ah hello I just realized that
it's been a while since I've cleaned up
I was not expecting to have company so
soon there are probably a lot of things
lying about here and there you can pick
them up but do not carry more than you
need someday you might see something you
really like you'll want to leave a room
in your pockets for that okay thank you
should I have non-god the jug full of
spiders in the spider doughnut because
I'm pretty sure that I got those things
and I don't know started growing tah-dah
okay the so bizarre that the entire game
is designed around like being merciful
to people that's really interesting
there's just one switch oh yeah and
where is it is it downstairs somewhere
boink oh hey I got it what are you who
defunct it but there's also other stuff
over here there's like a radish or
something oh hey that's a toy today hey
are you doing devourer God no hello
plants can't talk dummy
oh damn it I wasn't ready how about
dinner you pat your stomach that detroit
offers a healthy meal eat your greens I
don't think I want to eat my green Oh
okay you pie your stomach that toy is
often okay I'll get this green this time
I'll get it baby
oh yeah I got it I did it I did it ha ha
no I did I ate too green
oh boy no why is it is this gonna be
another vegetable hello there a veggie
tied I should have known this I got the
truck on the first try I got what I
needed to do come on
feed me baby feed me yeah oh there we go
I guess I only need don't even me the
green some of these people I probably
don't even did like talk to first
okay I don't know if there's anything
else special there may not have been but
there might have been you never know
these things
Oh God oh it's the ghosty - I want to
talk to ghosty oh [ __ ]
Luke's hey Luke's why would I pick on
you finally I know I would never I'm so
nice I'm the nicest oh I got it and I
got gold - I want talk to ghosty again
hey ghosty poo how's going
I fell down a hole now I can't get up
going without me wait ghosts can fly
Gandhi
oh well Oh bye-bye then
glad I could give that encouraging
speech that probably has a profound
effect on what I want to be dealing with
down the road
hello people here how's it going the far
doors not an exit it simply marks a
rotation in perspective
it's a switch present sure why not
nothing happened great glad I did that
fun fun fun it's a switch present sure
yeah
nothing happened awesome so glad this is
all happening into my life
this is which present sure nothing
happened
oh boy this is the best all right so
this should rotate the room I guess so
oh well then I guess I goofed ah okay so
now let's see if you can read this
press the blue switch I know where the
blue switch is it's right here yes it's
a change in perspective oh I'm heart
hello
I've enjoyed oh how am I gonna eat your
green and avoid him at the same time
dinner didn't me come on come on give me
a little give me a little some some I'm
gonna try to eat my greens
Oh God aha got it I nailed it I'm the
best okay mercy on there we go swing
your arms baby I don't know if I want to
but I'll try
maybe okay bye bye bye okay cool so this
should be
after I get this one now the change in
perspective if you can read this
press the red switch okay this is not
gonna work somehow isn't it
oh I did it okay it works I didn't
expect to do but hey there it is okay so
one more change in perspective there was
a sign right here
oh no it's up there I thought they were
gonna hide it secretly hmm hello Luke's
but if you can read this press the green
switch okay so green switch was right
here yep oh look at that
I remember simple things these puzzles
are easy even for my brain which is very
good yes oh hi oh dear that took longer
than I thought it would huh
ring oh hi how did you get here my child
are you hard there there I will heal you
I should not have left you alone for so
long it was irresponsible of me to try
to surprise you like this oh well I
suppose I cannot hide it any longer come
small one I've prepared you for dinner
okay let me say it first before I do
this seeing such a cute tiny house in
those ruins gives you determination okay
yay i'm playing undertale and i
hopefully i'm doing it correctly I have
no idea if I am but there it is so thank
you everybody so much for watching I
don't know how long this game is I don't
think it's a longest game in the world
considering it has replay value but I'm
gonna do a completionist playthrough
expect videos every day
until it's done so thank you again
everybody for watching and as always I
will see you in the next video
you see he won't succeed yours not
nobody is gonna find a phantom doesn't
offices but God's them happen